tu vois là il est presque l'heure de se
rendre à l'elysée pour la traditionnelle
intervention du président de la
république jacques chirac qui est
interrogé aujourd'hui par arlette chabot
de france 2 et patrick poivre d'arvor de
tf1 on se retrouve juste après pour un
journal complet bonsoir à tous bonjour à
tous nous voici donc en direct des
jardins l'elysée pour accueillir et
questionné le président de la république
monsieur le président bonjour bonjour
interview dans laquelle avec arlette
chabot nous allons essayer de répondre
au maximum de questions que se posent
les français des questions concrètes
soit le chômage les 35 heures la
sécurité sociale la croissance qui
semble repartir la fiscalité
annie la violence à sécurité
l'immigration et puis aussi bien sûr les
sujets comme la cohabitation et
jugement vous portez et sur votre
gouvernement et sur l'opposition ça fait
beaucoup de questions bien sûr mais on
va essayer d'y répondre à un petit peu
plus rapidement qu'à l'habitude en trois
quarts d'heure c'est possible en disons
au fond une mi temps avec des espaces
assez courte parce qu'il est assez clair
que vous êtes un petit peu comme tous
les français
vous êtes sur un petit nuage trente six
heures après la victoire de l'équipe de
france de football
à votre avis comment aimé jacquet est il
arrivé ce à quoi les politiques cours
assez souvent désespérément sert à la
confiance
d'abord il a une compétence
naturellement ce qui lui a permis
d'arriver à ce résultat mais je peux
aussi parce qu'il incarne peu le
français dans ce qu'il a de meilleur
sérieux déterminé humain proche des gens
comprenant les autres et tolérant mais
ferme enfin il a de grandes qualités
est ce que à votre sens c'est un facteur
cette victoire tout ce qui s'est passé
autour de la coupe du monde c'est un
facteur de cohésion sociale
d'intégration ou est ce que comme
certains le disent d'une façon 2011 ne
pas penser aux grands problèmes du monde
et se laver la tête
je crois qu'un peuple
a besoin à certains moments de se
retrouver se retrouver ensemble et donc
je retrouvais autour d'une idée qui le
rend fier de lui-même et au fond cette
victoire à montrer la solidarité la
cohésion
elle a montré que la france avait une
âme ou plus exactement
peut-être qu'elle recherchait une âme et
je souhaite qu'au lendemain du décès
faite ce jour de fête on conserve
quelque chose de fort de ce sentiment
national j'ai président prolongée zidane
djorkaeff sur les nouvelles idoles et
puis un kart 7
cette france un peu plus rien alors est
ce que c'est un coup de pouce à
l'intégration est un coup de frein
racisme à votre avis identification
savez la france historiquement à une
origine plus rien
nous revendiquons car maintenant c'est
aux origines judéo-chrétienne latine
no le fait que nous descendons des
gaulois ce qui n'a rien à voir et nous
avons pays dont le nom la france est
emprunté à d'autres tribus les frappes
étaient balisés mans il ya donc un
ensemble partagé qui fait peut-être que
la france a été le pays qui a le mieux
ressenti compris la nécessité de
l'intégration et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
cette équipe à la fois tricolore et
multicolore donne une belle image de la
france dans ce qu'elle a dû manistes ans
qu'elle a le fort parce que la drass en
bleu et ce matin je regardais le
tu vas dans le défilé de codifier et
je voyais aussi ce qu'on ne souligne pas
assez que l'armée française qui a été
ovationné sur les champs elysées elle
est également à la fois multicolores et
ricol tout cela donne une belle image de
la france disait justement ton français
sont heureux on les a vues francs du
drapeau s'embrasser on dit même si c'est
assez semblable à libération c'est donc
un moment fort est ce que votre avis
donc c'est l'effet coupe du monde ou
bien est ce que les français franchement
sont plus déprimées du tout d'abord nous
avons donné l'image d'une france qui
gagne et d'une france qui gagne
quand sans ça c'est extraordinairement
porte une france qui pour une fois
s'éloigne des mesquineries des querelles
subalternes dans nous avons un certain
secret et ça c'était quelque chose qui a
été certainement ressenti très fortement
souvent dit que votre rêve au fond si
vous aviez tes joueurs en tout cas et
aura été d'être gaullistes vers l'ultime
rempart
aujourd'hui on a envie de vous demander
à quoi sert exactement le priant la
république et on le voit comme super
supporter numéro 1 on le voit comme
pierre péan en chef de la maison france
est-ce que vous avez bien trouvé vos
marques dans cette nouvelle cohabitation
savez il faut d'abord se référer à nos
institutions à notre culture notre
tradition démocratique républicaine le
rôle du président de la république c'est
d'abord d'incarner
les institutions et de les garanties
garantir le bon fonctionnement parce que
ça c'est la base même de la démocratie
et
la cohésion sociale donc c'est l'ultime
rempart oui c'est aussi rôle du
président est aussi de défendre les
intérêts de la france ses intérêts à
moyen et long terme lorsqu'il s'agit de
son l'évolution de son adaptation à
derrière aux problèmes de demain et puis
aussi ses intérêts à l'extérieur sa
défense bien entendu mais s'est attiré
commerciaux ses intérêts politiques ou
culturelles salon d'un particulier
et de ce point de vue mon rôle est à la
fois de prendre des initiatives pour
encourager voire décidé les réformes
importantes vous parlions du 14 juillet
je les fais pour les armes et en
traitant des armées où la justice c'est
aussi de donner l'impulsion en ce qui
concerne la place de la france dans le
monde en europe appartient avec les
gouvernements bien entendu il n'ya pas
coupure entre le gouvernement et plus
dans la république
ces domaines tu es aussi la place de la
france alors dans le monde un monde qui
devient de plus en plus multipolaire et
où la france doit avoir un rôle
important
s'il ya un nom je souhaite que la
cohabitation qui démarrait son soutien à
l'ancien hôtel consultiez comment le
décès ainsi que je la veux et c'est
ainsi que je la vis et
il ne peut pas y avoir à mon avis sauf
crise politique majeure
puma des événements imprévisibles
exceptionnel et ne peut pas et ne doit
pas y avoir de tiraillements la france
doit parler d'une même voix l'extérieur
c'est ce qu'elle fait et la france dans
ta vie à l'homme démocratique doit
trouver les bonnes voies d'évolution à
l'atelier vous ne marchez jamais sur les
pieds ya pas de tacles une d'y avoir de
luton incident
taillon volontaire ou non mais
globalement je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'ils marchent que donne la france l
extérieur c'est ça qui est important de
voir soit une image mauvaise je ne le
ressens pas non plus pour ce qui
concerne les français qui n'ont pas
absorbé t-il de critiques a exprimé en
ce qui concerne le fonctionnement de la
cohabitation j'y suis très très sensible
ça suit l'histoire le dira le
gouvernement est apprécié par les
français en tout cas c'est ce que disent
les sondages
davantage que le précédent vous aviez
nommé la croissance retrouvée y est
certainement pour quelque chose mais est
ce que ce gouvernement est pour quelque
chose dans la croissance d'une part et
et que faire des fruits de cette
croissance retrouvée
c'est d'abord la croissance
revient ça ne fait aucun doute c'est un
phénomène européen jeudi européen parce
que ce n'est pas vrai dans l'ensemble du
monde
nous avons une crise préoccupante en
asie ce qui peut avoir le cas échéant
des répercussions chez nous même si elle
n'a pas eu jusqu'ici notamment grâce à
la perspective de l'euro qui a donné
confiance aux marchés en ce qui concerne
lente et cette croissance
cela nous donner des moyens
supplémentaires elle va permettre de
réduire le chômage notamment pour ce qui
concerne les jeunes et nous devons être
attentifs au fait que la croissance
n'est pas suffisante pour réduire le
chômage de longue durée qui a plutôt eu
tendance à augmenter
et ça c'est un grand problème c'est le
chômage de longue durée c'est par là que
passe l'exclusion et donc il ya là
quelque chose de très très important
maîtriser le chômage baisse quand même
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant et non
des jeunes le chômage global est
globalement quand mais le chômage de
longue durée a tendance à augmenter
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus inquiétant est
donc je pense que nous devons faire un
effort particulier pour réduire le
chômage de longue durée car je le répète
au delà de ce chômage c'est l'exclusion
ou pas fait que c'est ce gouvernement
qui a trouvé enfin la bonne clé pour
faire baisser le chômage le gouvernement
à ses responsabilités mais il faut
savoir que dans le domaine économique
notamment
internationale il ya ses chromes à un
grand paquebot ça ne vire pas comme une
barque et par conséquent la situation
que nous connaissons actuellement est
due pour une bonne part et à
l'assainissement des finances publiques
était lui le fruit des efforts des
gouvernements précédents il ne faut tout
de même pas l'oublier
si nous connaissons si nous avons un
terrain propice à la croissance
aujourd'hui c'est pour une large part
grâce aux efforts qui ont été ceux des
deux gouvernements précédents et qui ont
été d'ailleurs je dois le dire poursuivi
par ce gouvernement pas vos pas ignorer
les responsabilités des uns par rapport
aux autres répartition des fruits de la
croissance vous parlez de des réductions
du déficit est ce qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin que le fait aujourd'hui
gouvernement qui se fixe un objectif de
2,3 l'année prochaine et ce qu'il faut
baisser les impôts comment fait-on je
crois que
la france a de grands atouts qu'elle a
des handicaps parmi ces handicaps il ya
une certaine facilité à dépenser de
l'argent sans d'ailleurs toujours
contrôler exactement l'efficacité de la
dépense et je crois effectivement que
nous devons lutter contre cette tendance
sans aucun doute réduire les déficits
plus encore avec 2,3 pour cent douce ou
encore parmi les moins bons de l'union
européenne je le crois et deuxièmement
il faut tu diminues et ce tout à fait
impératif la pression fiscale qui est
tout à fait excessif qui est la plus
élevée de l'union européenne et qui est
tout à fait excessive
ce qui suppose naturellement une
maîtrise des dépenses alors justement
grillage au spa avait promis pendant sa
campagne qui baisseraient la terrre à ce
que ça vous paraît être la bonne piste
la priorité en ce qui concerne la
réduction justement décès s'installe
ça c'est un problème qui concerne le
gouvernement ce qui est sûr peut pas
montrer aujourd'hui dans le détail
naturellement ce qui est sûr c'est que
la pression fiscale dans notre pays doit
être diminuée sinon c'est un handicap
sérieux pour notre compétitivité dans un
monde où la compétitivité de plus en
plus importante
parler du chômage et de la baisse du
chômage ya les 35 heures alors on
connaît les réserves que vous avez
formulé à plusieurs reprises à l'égard
de la loi
est ce qu'on fout il n'y a pas un côté
positif des négociations vont s'engager
un peu partout sur des branches dans les
branches professionnelles dans les
entreprises qui permettra peut-être qui
permettront peut-être d'introduire
souplesse ou sexualité sont
effectivement que les négociations se
développe
je le souhaite beaucoup car
une conception de la vie sociale dans
notre pays qui passe par le
développement de la concertation et la
diminution des affrontements souvent
stériles et
et ces négociations commente je persiste
à penser qu' il est très difficile
d'appliquer ce genre de règles de façon
uniforme et total sous forme de couperet
et que si nos missions des 35 heures une
ambition légitime et elle devrait être
laissé pour ce qui concerne sa mise en
oeuvre à l'appréciation des négociations
locales jeudi de l'entreprise par
entreprise est revenu sur un nombre de
dispositions notamment sur les
allocations familiales est ce qu'à votre
avis ça va dans le bon sens et est par
ailleurs est ce que vous trouvez qu'on
honore suffisamment la famille
traditionnelle aujourd'hui ou es ce que
vous avez des inquiétudes sur la manière
dont pourrait se dérouler désormais les
unions les mariages je ne sais pas ce
que vous appelez la famille
traditionnelle
ce que le sait c'est que la famille est
et reste la cellule de base de la
société celle où on acquiert
les qualités nécessaires pour assumer
son épanouissement et son existence et
que la famille
en période de crise comme celle que nous
connaissons et de surpoids
l'ultime est le meilleur rempart aux
détresses à l'exclusion etc et donc il
faut renforcer la famille
il faut la renforcer notamment trois
raisons nous devons donner davantage de
facilités aux femmes qui travaillent
nous devons renforcer les moyens
d'éducation des enfants au sein de la
famille c'est là où leur donne les
principes qui sont nécessaires pour le
comportement ultérieur et il faut la
renforcer pour des raisons
démographiques sommes l'avenir de notre
pays dépend de la démographie qui dépend
de la famille la caractéristique d'une
politique familiale c'est que le niveau
de vie moyen des familles s'accroissent
plus vite que le niveau de vie moyenne
damnation ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire récemment que
je le regrette et sur la ged justement
sur une femme qui travaille le retour
dont on m'a vraiment ça vous paraît
d'ascendant n'entrons pas dans le détail
il faut te aller plus fort plus loin
plus vite dans le renforcement des
moyens permettant à la famille de se
développer de jouer tout son rôle dans
la société qui est essentiel trouve face
au dérapage des dépenses de santé il
n'est pas le premier
alors aujourd'hui vous dit le plan juppé
était insuffisant et il fallait aller
plus loin si c'était possible ou bien
vous dites vrai gouvernement s'est pas
saisi assez tous les problèmes
la sécurité sociale c'est le bien de
toutes et tous les français y sont
attachés
et j'ai toujours dit dès mon élection
que j'étais le garant de la sécurité
sociale elle était en mauvais état il ya
quelques années et elle accumulé des
déficits qui mettait en cause son
existence où son avenir
il fallait donc réformer le gouvernement
de monsieur juppé a fait effectivement
une réforme importante
très attendus les réformes que j'ai
approuvé sans raison cette réforme était
importante parce que elle faisait de
rentrée le principe de responsabilité
dans la gestion de nos affaires sociales
le parlement pour la première fois votée
les objectifs de dépenses les caisses
s'engager les
la profession médicale et les hôpitaux
s'engager responsabilité des deux
premières années 96 et 97 ont vu les
dépenses de santé maîtriser leur rythme
assez cassé elles ont diminué sans pour
autant que ni les professionnels ni
naturellement les patients n'en
souffrent le moins du monde
c'est le système a pris c'est le système
qui s'est améliorée alors les dettes les
dérapages ont repris en 98 et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire au premier ministre
que je trouvais que son jugement et est
injustement sévère à l'égard du plan
juppé qu'en réalité c'est parce que
depuis un an on n'a pas fait en sorte
que ce qu'il prévoyait soit mis en
oeuvre sérieusement que nous nous
trouvons après cette immobilité en
quelque sorte ou en partie nous nous
trouvons dans une situation de dérapage
à nouveau des dépenses qui vont exiger
de nouvelles mesures mais je pense que
l'application stricte du plan juppé
aurait permis de régler une part
importante du problème de notre
l'assurance-maladie condition de l'être
d'y mettre les formes
oui probablement parlé du changement de
l'évolution du gouvernement à propos de
la famille notamment sur l'axé les
allocations familiales or il ya un autre
domaine l'impression que le gouvernement
change un peu c'est dans le domaine de
la sécurité notamment par la voix de
jean pierre chevènement le ministre de
l'intérieur qu'il y ait la sécurité
c'est une priorité est un droit
essentiel des français ce que vous
constatez vraiment cette évolution ce
qu'on leur connaissait pas puis je suis
tout à fait sensible à ce qui est fait
dans le domaine de la sécurité je ne
parle pas de la corse
j'approuve complètement la politique
qu'ils suivent il encore il faut aller
jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas et n'est pas
tolérable qu'il y est en france des
zones de non droit
la corse était la plus spectaculaire
mais il y en a d'autres arguments et
c'est un effort qui doit être permanent
et il ya la fois la sécurité qui est
probablement avec le chômage la
principale préoccupation de nos
compatriotes
il ya le sentiment d'insécurité
qui est également psychologique mans
grave et puis il y à l'incivilité qui se
développe terrible les femmes injurié
vous agresser dans le métro après tout
les uns civile ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les incivilités c'est à dire
les petites agressions qui rendent la
vie impossible
là il faut lutter avec beaucoup de
fermeté ça ne se fera pas du jour au
lendemain contre cette dérive qu'il faut
d'abord finir moi j'ai rassemblé j'ai
réuni et pour de longs entretiens d'une
part des maires de villes difficile et
de toutes origines politiques
de même j'ai réuni des chefs
d'établissement d'établissements
difficiles ils sont unanimes quelle que
soit leur appartenance politique ou
syndicale ils disent une fois puni
notamment les jeunes car l'insécurité
venant des jeunes et de plus en plus
jeunes est un problème majeur
il faut punir et punir vite tout
naturellement après sont gardés mais il
faut punir et punis immédiatement sans
délai deuxièmement il faut de renforcer
là encore le rôle de la famille c'est
dans la famille que l'on peut acquérir
les principes qui permettent d'avoir un
comportement responsable
c'est globalement une meilleure
éducation civique et dans l'argile
également une éducation civique à
l'école besoins seront peut-être et
enfin il faut avoir une coordination qui
s'est beaucoup améliorée mais qui doit
être encore renforcée une
coopération entre les différents
responsables qu'il s'agisse de la police
de la justice de l'éducation nationale
des services sociaux des éducateurs etc
il faut de bien meilleure coordination
sur les rails son prochain je crois que
nous sommes effectivement pour le moment
sur le bon chemin avec un certain nombre
de difficultés auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés et qui tienne
toutes sortes de 2,2 de dérapage que
nous voyons bien et qu'il faut
absolument maîtriser et pour ma part je
considère que cette indépendamment des
problèmes économiques liés aux champs et
leurs conséquences en matière de chômage
c'est la préoccupation essentielle qui
doit être celle des résultats et sur
l'éducation et de la société française
vous paraît adapté au monde moderne
on critique toujours beaucoup notre
éducation et il ya probablement lieu de
critiquer je constate que tous les
responsables économiques sont unanimes
pour dire qu'en france nous avons les
meilleurs
la meilleure formation des sols c'est
vrai en particulier pour les ingénieurs
pour les techniciens qui nous sont
enviées dans le monde entier et qui sont
l'une l'un de nos atouts et alors
naturellement il faudrait se fixé
quelques objectifs ne promet pas de la
gestion actuelle naturellement mais
quelques objets les rythmes scolaires il
faut arriver à ce que
les enfants travaillent le matin pour
les disciplines de la connaissance et
l'après midi pour ce qui concerne le
sport les disciplines artistiques
l'accès à la culture l'accès aux
technologies modernes
il faut également que on met en place
enfin un système de formation et
d'éducation tout au long de la vie pour
que les gens puissent en permanence
acquérir les nouvelles connaissances qui
sont nécessaires dans les nouveaux
métiers qui arrivent de plus en plus
vives il faut également éradiquer
l'illettrisme dans ce domaine on n'a pas
fait de progrès depuis 30 ans 40 ans et
l'illettrisme est aujourd'hui
l'inconvénient le plus
plus manifeste pour l'insertion dans la
société et enfin je crois qu'il faut que
on est on développe le trilinguisme
c'est à dire que tous les enfants et
notamment en europe devraient apprendre
dès le plus jeune âge de langues
étrangères
il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui sont pris
lundi en europe ou dans le monde profane
ou et ça permettrait justement aux
étrangers de parler plus des
fondamentalistes ça permettrait de
réimplanter le français en europe
naturellement le titre ici on vous dira
le point que je ne peux pas régler celui
des sans papiers est ce que le
gouvernement a trouvé un équilibre au
rayon des cas est difficile et en
refusant de régulariser tout nous est ce
que votre avis il est il s'est créé
lui-même sorte de piège dans ce domaine
je suis un peu critique donc seulement
l'égard d'une situation actuelle mais de
la situation depuis longtemps je crois
que l'essentiel c'est de prendre une
position et de s'y tenir et il faut être
pragmatique et non pas idéologue dans ce
sujet alors il faut dire voilà pouvons
pas naturellement laissé entrer tout le
monde chez nous voilà les limites par la
tranche here
et voilà les mesures nous nous
acquittons pour que ces limites soit
1,36 et puis le plus changé
chaque fois qu'un changement de
gouvernement nous avons un changement
des lois
ça c'est typiquement français ayant
naturellement ça envoie des signaux
contradictoires et très bombée parce que
les gens sont patients encouragé à venir
chez nous ils se disent ah quand les
gens sont au pouvoir alors c'est plus
facile on le précipite et quand les mots
ce sont des débats stériles tout à fait
stérile et il faut avoir une
réglementation et s'y tenir et à mon
avis ce après l'augmentation doit être
ferme
vous parlez de régularisation c'est très
bien s'il ya des gens qui doit être
régularisée qu'ils le soient
naturellement je sais bien qu'il faut
seulement une gestion humaine de ces
affaires mais on oublie que la
régularisation est un amplificateur
important de l'immigration monsieur
comme vous le savez quand le régulariser
acquiert le droit familial le droit de
faire venir les gens de sa famille et
donc vous croyez régulariser une
personne est en réalité vous en
régulariser d'une série
le rapprochement familial joue dans ce
sens donc il faut être prudent alors sur
la justice maintenant pragmatique vous
nous aviez donné l'impression il ya un
an et demi
deux des traînées de joueurs de devoir
couper le cordon ombilical entre le
pouvoir et le parquet et les sentiments
de dison au fil du temps de revenir un
petit peu sur cette position de principe
parce que vous êtes content finalement
de ce que propose le gouvernement
propose puisque je sais que sur ce sujet
il vous a évidemment beaucoup consulté
il ya eu beaucoup de cas d'entre vous il
ya en france
naturellement une très bonne justice et
là des défauts c'est des fois il faut
les corriger
d'où l'idée d'une grande réforme de la
justice portant sur plusieurs années
que j'ai lancée et que je suis qui était
fondée sur le rapport de la commission
truche qui doit à mon avis être
appliquée qui est fondée sur trois
volets essentiels
le premier volet ses rangs avoir une
justice plus rapide moins cher plus
profs et ça ça suppose une réforme
importante des procès du mur et ça
suppose une augmentation des moyens mis
à la disposition de la justice
le deuxième volet c'est le renforcement
des garanties du justiciable
et ce qui suppose une réforme des
procédures prédalles et l'affirmation
claire des droits de l'homme et de la
présomption d'innocence
ce mât pays qui aimons donner des leçons
en matière de droits de l'homme à la
terre entière
on a raison c'est probablement dans
notre vocation mais qui ne regarde pas
son propre sa propre situation ou au
titre de la présomption d'innocence et
de sa de son non respect les droits de
l'homme sont souvent comme au titre de
la détention provisoire purement et
simplement foulé aux pieds et il ya donc
là quelque chose qui doit être rétablie
et le troisième volet c'est
l'indépendance et la responsabilité des
juges indépendance et responsabilité car
l'indépendance des juges ne peut être
acceptée est elle nécessaire bien
entendu mais elle ne peut être acceptée
que si par ailleurs les juges sont
responsables
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il le soit
suffisamment aujourd'hui et parfois vous
trouvez qu'on est à deux doigts d'un
gouvernement des juges
ou en faire tout en étant toujours
d'ailleurs pouvoir on étend en tous les
cas a souvent à 2,3 à deux doigts de la
mise en cause des principes
constitutionnels relatifs aux droits de
femmes alors puisqu'on parle justement
de la présomption d'innocence
est-ce que la mise en cause et la mise
en examen de roland dumas président du
conseil constitue l vous vous paraît
nuire à la sérénité de cette institution
qui est pas censé donner droit suprême
dans l'état des choses
l'institution fonctionne pour monsieur
roland dumas il y à ce qui relève de la
justice j'ai pas de jugement à porter il
y à ce qui relève de sa conscience
je n'ai pas non plus de jugement à
porter il ya ce qui relève de ma
responsabilité c'est à dire comme vous
le dites le bon fonctionnement d'une
institution essentielle de la république
pour le moment j'ai bon fonctionnement
n'est pas contre grande réforme c'est la
modernisation de la vie politique que
vous l'avez souhaité ou non non les
élections régionales et cantonales vous
avez consulté reçu des spécialistes et
puis les élus les français es ce que
vous avez trouvé une idée nouvelle on
discute on avec ce que vous avez vu
d'abord je n'ai pas terminé ma réflexion
ensuite le gouvernement réfléchit
également
je suis d'ailleurs longuement entretenu
tout récemment avec le premier ministre
et nous avons décidé de nous entretenir
à nouveau et donc je vous fais si vous
voulez en un maul le point de ma
réflexion
il y a incontestablement une
désaffection à l'égard de la vie
publique de la part de beaucoup de
français l'âge et ginza suffit d'avoir
la coupe du monde de football pour qu'un
enthousiasme le nouveau arrive qu'elle
opposait de la désaffection
on n'a pas vu cet enthousiasme alors
comment qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire je
crois qu'il faut d'abord renouveler et
renouveler ça veut dire davantage de
femmes dans la vie publique
alors les textes sont en cours et la
réforme bonne réforme va être mise en
oeuvre davantage de jeunes
ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas facile
mais il faut les inciter davantage à
s'engager revoir probablement le statut
de l'élu je veux dire le statut de l'élu
du parlementaire il ya deux sortes de
parlementaire en france et ce n'est pas
juste
il ya ceux qui ont une garantie c'est à
dire les fonctionnaires au sens très
large du terme
jo y sont battus il retrouve tout
naturellement leur position en carrière
et donc leurs moyens de vivre et ceux
qui n'ont pas de ces garanties parce
qu'ils viennent du secteur privé quel
qu'il soit et celà esi beaucoup à se
présenter parce que le jour où ils sont
petits n'ont plus les moyens de vivre
peut-être qu'elle est une écurie t il il
faut ou retirer les sécurité ou établir
un filet de sécurité pour les autres
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ceci dit
randy forme la représentation nationale
salah d'efforts le manque de femmes et
le manque de gens venant de la société
civile au sens le plus large du terme
des formes la représentation nationale
au profit d'une catégorie qui sont
essentiellement les hommes
fonctionnaires au sens très large du
terme
je caricature vous le comprenez bien
mais c'est un problème donc
renouvellement est deuxième
deuxième élément il faut plus de
proximité et d'efficacité au fond
l'administration est trop omnipotente
est omniprésente
il faut qu'elle comprenne et que petit à
petit les réformes soient mises en
oeuvre qu'elle doit moins contraindre et
davantage aidés aussi bien les citoyens
que les entreprises
tout le monde a pu tremper fini c'est
vrai vous avez raison mais sa maladie
mais il ne faut pas pour autant se
décourager et on a tout de même fait des
progrès la décentralisation était un
progrès elle est inachevée mais c'est un
progrès et de ce point de vue il est
évidente il faut notamment et avoir une
administration qui pèse moins lourdement
sur nos finances publiques
25% des français actifs travaillent
pour le service public et 15 % des
allemands ou des anglais
c'est très très caractéristique de la
france et deuxièmement il faut tu avoir
un système qui rapproche la décision des
deux ce qu'elle concerne et on appelle
ça la décentralisation la
déconcentration peu importe il faut
qu'un certain nombre de décisions prêts
qui sont encore prises à paris soit
dorénavant prises beaucoup plus près du
terrain et des contribuables et puis le
troisième point c'est la morale et la
responsabilité
il faut redonner toute son importance et
sa valeur à la morale comme valeurs
démocratiques et républicaines
et de ce point de vue il y a à faire
alors naturellement je combats vivement
l'idée que la france serait un pays
corrompu
l'image qu'on en donne parfois qui est
totalement dépourvue de tout fondement
même si naturellement existe des gens
malhonnêtes
il y en a toujours eu et il y en aura
toujours il faut les rechercher et les
sanctionner
mais le rétablissement la réhabilitation
de la morale est essentielle elle
suppose vous en parliez tout à l'heure
dès le plus jeune âge l'instruction
civique la réhabilitation des principes
elle suppose aussi et un contrôle
peut-être plus strictes du domaine
politico administratives
on a déjà fait des progrès avec les
réformes pour le financement des partis
politiques mais le contrôle notamment
des marchés publics doit être beaucoup
plus importants pour que la situation
soit plus transparente et enfin les
sages suis beaucoup peur je me suis
beaucoup investi dans ce domaine la
grande corruption tenant aux grands
marchés internationaux
les grands contrats internationaux vous
avez la première chose que j'ai faite
lorsque j'ai été élu c'était de
convoquer mon premier ministre à
l'époque juppé mon ministre des de la
défense monsieur millon pour leur donner
des instructions extrêmement ferme dans
ce domaine est la première chose que
j'ai fait lorsque monsieur jospin a été
nommé ainsi que monsieur richard la
défense était la même chose
je leur ai dit attention voilà les
risques que l'on court je ne veux plus
que des grands scandales comme ceux que
l'on évoque ici ou là dans le monde
puisse se reproduire et je dois dire que
aujourd'hui en france il ne pourrait pas
sur le co2 décision soler réforme
engagée discrètement le gouvernement
haïtien saint wasnon sur le cumul des
mandats par exemple vous allez faire en
sorte que toutefois pas bloqué au sénat
les photos nous rentrons pas dans le
détail mais je suis favorable à la
réglementation du cumul des mandats
ensuite ce qu'il faut un mandat de lula
c'est une discussion au parlement et
mais je suis favorable au cumul des
mandats c'est l'un l'une des conditions
du renouvellement dont je parlais tout
est il favorable aussi à la modification
du mode de scrutin aux européennes
également l objet de faire marche
arrière c'est un petit peu aussi votre
un revers pour vous savez c'est un
problème moi je me suis prononcée il ya
plus d'un an pour ce scrutin par grandes
circonscriptions
mais j'ai toujours dit c'est un problème
qui concerne le parlement les partis
politiques et donc qu'il faut s'en
remettre à leurs falaises la majorité à
l'évidence de l'assemblée nationale n'y
était pas favorable
il était normal de retirer ce que je
vois pas du tout pourquoi on en a fait
tout l'émission c'est le fonctionnement
naturel de la démocratie même d'animaux
sur la prostitution nous dira par
exemple un 14 juillet qu'il est
favorable au quinquennat et qui savent
que tout le monde est pour au début oui
à berlin d'un genre
je crois que ce n'est pas un problème
personnel puisque comme vous le dites il
appartient au président ensuite de dire
si oui ou non il se l'appliqué des non
simplement
c'est une réforme très lourd de
conséquences très doux et
avec le septennat nous avons un système
souple originale qui a très bien
fonctionné et qui a permis à nos
institutions de s'adapter
ce système là sa responsabilité au
gouvernement et donne de la durée au
président avec le quinquennat c'est un
système tout à fait différent alors qui
doit qui normalement débouche sur un
régime présidentiel est alors le régime
présidentiel ça marche aux états unis
plus ou moins bien car vous voit
aujourd'hui qu'avec un congrès hostile
au président il est très difficile oui
il est très difficile au président de
prendre des décisions
enfin ça marche mais ça marche parce
qu'à une culture américaine qui n'est
pas du tout une culture idéologique
d'une culture pragmatique en france je
suis persuadé qu'un régime présidentiel
très rapidement il est au blocage
complet des institutions entre des
opinions différentes et lors si ce n'est
pas l'évolution vers le quinquennat si
ce n'est pas l'évolution vers le régime
présidentiel
alors ça ne peut être que l'évolution
vers le régime parlementaire intégral
c'est-à-dire ce que nous avons connu
sous la quatrième république
c'est-à-dire l'impuissance et la
paralysie de la nation donc je le répète
je vois beaucoup de gens très savants
très compétents qui sont favorables au
quinquennat peut-être mais ça mérite en
tous les cas une réflexion très
approfondie savez la france a une espèce
de caractéristiques là encore c'est
l'exception française qui peut être la
meilleure
comme il ya deux jours où la pire et
l'exception française une de ses
caractéristiques c'est chaque fois qu'il
ya quelque chose qui ne va pas on veut
changer les institutions
si bien que diable pays qui a connu le
plus grand nombre de constitution de
toute l'histoire du groupe
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon
nous avons les probablement les
meilleurs juristes du monde ça de grands
avantages savane inconvénient ce qu'ils
ont toujours eu d'idées à défendre pour
faire quelque chose de nouveau par
rapport à ce qui existe ça peut être
dangereux
on parle en ce moment beaucoup de ce qui
rassemble les français notamment grâce
au football il ya un sujet qui va sans
doute à nouveau les diviser dans les
semaines qui viennent à propos de
l'europe
la ratification du traité d'amsterdam
alors l'euro est lancé mais il ya ce
problème devant nous est ce que vous
continuez dire au fond à droite comme à
gauche c'est l'opposition entre les
anciens et les modernes
c'est un peu caricatural moi je les ai
marre j'en ai dit je suis tout prêt à le
répéter parce qu'il ya du vrai même si
je le répète elle c'est une affirmation
tout petit peu caricatural c'est vrai
qu'il y a
si vous voulez la france que nous avons
vu dans la rue le 12 juillet au soir et
qui était à la fois une france moderne
une france j'en suis sûr européenne
d'ailleurs tous les sondages disent que
les jeunes sont très largement
favorables la construction européenne et
une frange de l'avenir et puis à c'est
vrai les gens qui ont des problèmes des
difficultés qui sont tous les jours
confronté à
d
des événements qui nous ont du mal à
maîtriser
généralement des gens souvent plus âgés
et je comprends parfaitement que ces
gens ont peur en réalité du changement
quel qu'il soit de la réforme quelle
qu'elle soit et moi je voudrais
simplement leur dire que nous sommes
dans un monde où se dessine et se met en
place très rapidement de très grands
ensembles politiques économiques
culturelles les états unis la chine de
malades
l'ensemble de l'amérique du sud l'asie
du sud est
la russie qui sortira bien sûr de ses
difficultés et le japon malgré aussi ses
difficultés actuelles et alors nous
divisent les refermer replié sur lui sur
nous mêmes il faut savoir que nous
disparaîtrons et que notre seule chance
d'avoir un rôle dans le monde de
défendre nos valeurs d'assumer notre
niveau de vie notre mode de vie c'est de
le faire ensemble d'avoir une europe
solidaire qui représente aujourd'hui 300
350 millions d'habitants demain 500 qui
sera le premier pôle économique
elle l'est déjà où est donc le premier
pôle politique car elle est aussi le
premier pôle culturel
c'est là que nous avons nos chances à la
fois de développement d'épanouissement
et surtout de rester ce que nous avons
vocation être c'est-à-dire un grand pôle
de démocratie de droits de l'homme et de
mieux vivre qu'ailleurs ce discours vous
obligé de tenir à vos amis du rpr qui se
partagent beaucoup aussi à les anciens
et les modernes et vos décisions rire
ligne b mais c'est normal c'est ça aussi
la la discussion là je ne conteste à
personne le droit d'avoir des idées
différentes des miennes je dis
simplement que je ne détermine pas mes
idées par rapport à celles des autres y
compris des miens vous avez parlé du rpr
je suis issu de cette formation
politique et je ne ris je ne renie rien
ni de mon passé li de ses ambitions
naturellement mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que je ne me détermine pas par
rapport aux autres je me détermine par
rapport à l'idée que je me fais de
l'intérêt général et de l'intérêt de la
france
j'ai une conviction c'est que l'intérêt
de la france c'est d'être un élément
actif un moteur de la construction
européenne et que c'est ainsi
si seulement qu'elle défendra non
seulement ses intérêts mais aussi son
identité votre successeur à la tête du à
perfectionner un peu moins européen que
vous désespérez pas de le ramener à
laquelle on a donné raison
je n'ai strictement aucune aucun conseil
aucune leçon à donner à quiconque
dans le domaine des formations
politiques et même à mes amis du rpr et
même au président du rpr que je
j'approuve que je respecte et qui est un
de mes amis vous le savez de très longue
date qu'ils assument avec qualité la
présidence dans un moment difficile de
ce mouvement je donne simplement mon
sentiment d'opposition ce qui fait
d'avoir une silhouette ce que vous dites
bon moi j'étais ami me dit mais quand
même quand on voit une divergence sur le
roux il y en a eu sur la justice
le rpr a l'air d'être d'abord devriez
vous déjà non pas je vais vous dire
quelque chose
ahmed chagou vous avez commencé par la
constatation du grand du grand mouvement
qui a rassemblé les français et à ce
qu'ils se sont sentis tout d'un coup
fort uni respecter il suffit de lire la
presse et d'argent on s'en apercevoir il
ya alors naturellement la ville tous les
jours comporte son lot de médiocrité de
querelles et d'autres difficultés que je
peux parfaitement comprendre mais je
vous demande vous de comprendre que moi
ce n'est pas mon problème
pas du tout je sais que ça ne me
concerne pas j'irais même jusqu'à dire
que ça ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir
aujourd'hui une france qui a une
opportunité une grande opportunité qui
est une opportunité de rassemblement de
modernité qui l'a exprimé avec force
qu'il a exprimée il ya deux jours sur
les champs elysées match de finale qu'il
a exprimé ce matin sur les mêmes
s'organiser avec une belle armée 30,16
qui a donné une bonne image de notre
pays
je regardais en coin de temps en temps
l'ensemble des diplomates qui étaient là
tous les diplomates sont dans la tribune
et je voyais à la fois leurs intérêts
leurs un regard particulièrement
apprécié at her sûr
montre armées et au delà sur notre pays
et je voyais les gens descendent dans
les champs elysées pour passer les
troupes en revue qui était la plus
nombre d'habitudes et qui était
enthousiaste il se posait pas la
question de savoir si tel parti
politique et l autre se préoccupe de
ceci ou de cela ils étaient heureux
parce que il y avait du soleil qu'on
était champion du monde de football et
que l'armée française défile il ira ira
pas toujours du soleil en pâture des 14
juillet en match je vous tiens durera le
plus longtemps possible car on savait
quand même vous donneriez à l'opposition
c'est important si aujourd'hui un peu
sonné désorientés qui est atomisé mais
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
qu'elles s'unissent qu'elle aille vers
une fusion vers une alliance vers un
émiettement qui pour l'instant n'a pas
l'air de vous chagriner vos poules est
dans une démocratie doit y avoir une
majorité forte et une opposition pour ce
qui concerne l'opposition elle ne se
rend forte que si d'abord elle est punie
alors les modalités de cette union lui
appartiennent l'union n'est pas l'unité
mais elle doit être uni la deuxième
condition de son efficacité c'est
d'avoir une vision de l'avenir de
l'exprimer au sein d'un projet qui
puisse apparaître clairement dans
l'opinion publique comme une alternative
au projet de la majorité
ça va ça va venir sans aucun doute
et troisièmement il ne peut pas il est
nécessaire d'avoir une harmonie dans nos
institutions
parce qu'elles sont ainsi une harmonie
complète entre l'opposition et le
président de la république qui est issu
de ses rangs
de même qu'il doit y avoir même harmonie
entre la majorité et le président de la
république lorsqu'il est issu de ses
rangs par l'état leur identification de
la france cette équipe plus rien donc
plus que jamais hors de question de
passer des alliances pour selon vous
effectivement avec le front national et
tout débat sur la préférence nationale
et arrêtera d'y déplacer sur les
alliances vous connaissez mon point de
vue j'ai pas besoin de le répéter mais
sur la préférence nationale c'est un
débat qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
qui a provoqué beaucoup de passion de
débats
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un problème
un vrai problème
en revanche je pense que disserter
indéfiniment sur ce problème risque peut
devenir dangereux en clair et il y a
dans notre pays des étrangers en
situation régulière et je ne vois pas
le motif ou les raisons et compatibles
avec nos principes humanistes
démocratiques et républicains qui
permettrait de ne pas donner à ces
étrangers en situation régulière les
mêmes droits qu'aux français ça ce
serait tout à fait contraire à nos
traditions à notre histoire notre
culture dans tous les cas je ne pourrai
pas l'accepter et puis deuxièmement il
ya les étrangers qui sont en situation
irrégulière et cela il faut les expulser
alors j'entends bien que c'est plus vite
dit que fait mais nous devons non
seulement avoir un système qui nous
permet de sanctionner d'expulser avec
humanité bien entendu les étrangers en
situation irrégulière en plaisant péché
également d'entrée ça c'est tout à fait
capital et 7 dans ce système que je ne
vois pas très bien comment se situe le
débat sur les préférences monsieur à
l'instant bien entendre quelques
frémissements du côté de l'arrivée de
l'équipe de france vous avez vous même
votre petit coup ticks
je suis très fier c'est michel platini
qui me l'a donnée alors justement
dernière il est tout juste avait dit on
a beaucoup parlé on a beaucoup parlé de
ce mondial
faut pas oublier que il n'est pas sorti
du chapeau par un coup de baguette
magique à paris et y est pour quelque
chose
c'est surtout le comité d'organisation
michel platini le regretté fernand
sastre qui pendant 6 ans ont travaillé
et qui ont remarquablement organisé les
choses
c'est également tous les bénévoles
dizaines de milliers de bénévoles qui
ont permis à tous de se passer
parfaitement ce sont nos forces de
l'ordre qui ont été exemplaires
je veux lire dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles
c'est tout cela aussi qui a c'est notre
magnifique stade de saint-denis tout ça
ensemble a fait que nous trouvons
maintenant accueillir l'équipe de france
qui est en train d'arriver à l'elysée
vous l'entendez avec reconnaissance
estime et amitié
alors comme le on en a bien respecté les
contrats le trois quart d'heure juste
une mi-temps le quatrième arbitre nous
donne quand même les deux minutes de
prolongations nécessaire pour vous
demander à vous qui êtes au fond le
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france delà
de la france en tout cas comment vous la
santé quelles sont ses forces et
faiblesses
c'est la france à défense elle a de
l'intelligence une culture et un
humanisme qui font d'elle un pays
respecté tant mieux elle a une position
géographique elle a une formation
professionnelle je dédie tout al'air
exceptionnel les meilleurs ingénieurs et
techniciens du monde les travailleurs
aussi et
elle a des infrastructures qui sont
indiscutablement les meilleurs du monde
une recherche très fort ça ce sont les
atouts et la d
des insuffisances est là les handicaps
elle est imprévisible et on nous le
reproche beaucoup sur le plan social
pour un oui pour un non
il ya des mouvements qui prennent tout
le monde en otage tout d'un coup on
prend une mesure législative qui n'était
pas prévu et qui désert désarçonne les
investisseurs étrangers mais investit
surtout pour la loi sur les 35 heures a
été de tout ce domaine et
elle prend parfois des mesures fiscales
rétrospective
c'est incompréhensible pour l'étranger
elle a également une pression fiscale
beaucoup trop importante
elle a un travail peu qualifié trop cher
et elle a des tracasseries
administratives tout à fait accessible
donc ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est
valoriser nos atouts et 7 diminuer nos
handicaps et c'est ça qui devrait être
l'ambition à la fois de l'action du
gouvernement ou du programme de
l'opposition
et puis vous savez je voudrais terminer
juste dire une chose et vous n'avez vu
il s'est passé quelque chose
depuis quelques jours c'est à dire que
la france a retrouvé ce qu'elle a de
meilleur dans ses racines vous avez ici
3500 à 4000 jeunes puisque je l'invite
heures jeudi d'ailleurs nous entende et
mon tout ça parce que didier deschamps
et toute l'équipe est en train d'arriver
il faut naturellement avoir conscience
des besoins d'une société mais faut
aussi avoir conscience c'est parfois ce
qu'on a tendance à oublier de ses
aspirations ses aspirations intellectuel
culturel psychologique de son désir
d'union de cohésion de force comme on
l'a vu avec
ce match de football et je crois que
l'homme politique moderne aujourd'hui ne
devrait pas se contenter de dire je vais
vous donner cela comme on le fait en
général ils devraient dire aussi je vais
vous aider à devenir cela je crois que
c'est une des leçons que l'on peut tirer
de ces derniers choix vous laisser
rejoindre aimé jacquet quand on a
entendu beaucoup de cris jacquet
président quand même que vous alliez
vous inquiétez de situation je vais voir
et je vous remercie beaucoup nom
d'arlette chabot de france 2 était à de
nous avoir accueillis pendant ces trois
heures mais d'ici là
merci bon voilà et merci à vous d'être
resté avec